a
few weeks ago somebody tweeted during
the midterm elections in the United
States that Election Day should be made
a holiday and i retweeted saying well
you're welcome to come to my country and
vote you get the whole week off to allow
the military counted I come from Togo by
the way it is a beautiful country
located in West Africa but there are
some cool interesting facts about my
country Togo has been ruled by the same
family for 51 years making as the oldest
autocracy in Africa that's a record we
have a second cooler record we have been
ranked three times as done happiest
country on earth we all invited
so just to let you know it's not very
cool to live under an autocracy but the
interesting thing is that I have met for
the course of my activism so many people
from different countries and when I told
her about Togo the reaction is always
how can you guys allow the same people
to terrorize you for 51 years you know
like you do to believe you might be very
patient that's their diplomatic way of
saying stupid
you know and it's when you live in a
free country there's this tendency of
assuming that those who are oppressed
tolerate their oppression or are
comfortable with it and
democracy is projected as a progressive
form of governments in such a way that
those people who don't live on the
democratic countries as seen as people
who are not intellectually or may be
morally advanced as others but it's not
the case the reason why people have that
perception has to do with the way
stories are covered about dictatorships
in the course of my activism I've had to
interview with so many news outlets out
there and usually would always start
with what got you started how did you
what inspired you and I reply I wasn't
inspired I was triggered and
it goes on well what triggered you and I
go on about how my father was arrested
when I was 13 and tortured all the
history I don't get into details now
because you start sleeping but the thing
again of the day what interests them the
most is how was he tortured for how many
days how many people died they are
interested in the abuse in the killing
because they believe that will gain
attention and sympathy but in reality it
serves the purpose of the dictator it
helps them advertise the cruelty in 2011
I co-founded a movement I called for
Moscow because for is the first name of
our president Togo is a french-speaking
country by the way but I chose English
because I had my issues with friends as
well but then
but then when I started four must go I
made a video and I came on camera and I
said well funniest thing where I give
you 60 days to resign as president
because if you don't read a you f---ing
todo will organize and will bring you
down because you have killed over 500 of
our countrymen to size power when your
father died we have not chosen you
you're an impostor and we'll remove you
I was the only known face of the
movements why because I was the only
stupid one
and
the backlash is followed my family
started receiving threats my siblings
called me one morning and then they said
you know what when they come here to
kill you we don't want to die with you
so move out so yes I moved out and I'm
so angry at them so I haven't talked to
them in five years anyway um moving
forward the reason why for the past
eleven nine years that I've been working
with Congress to organize to raise
awareness on Togo to help people to
overcome their fear so they too can come
and say the one change I have receive a
lot of
persecutions that I can must disclose a
lot of tries a lot of abuse
psychologically but I don't like talking
about them because I know that my job as
an activist is to mobilize is to
organize is to help every single
Togolese citizen understand that as
citizens we hold the power we are the
boss and we decide and the punishment
that the dictators are using to
intimidate them must not prevent us from
getting what we want that
is why I said it is very important to
cover the stories of activists in a way
that it helped mobilize people not in a
way that it helped deter their action
and
Trust even more their subjugation to the
oppressive system
during those years that I've been an
activist there are days that I felt like
quitting because I couldn't take it but
then what kept me going the one thing
that kept me going I remember the story
of my grandfather and how he used to
walk
465 miles from his village to the city
just to protest for independence then I
remember the sacrifice of my father who
was tortured so many times for daring
you know protest against the regime back
in the 70s they will write pamphlets to
raise awareness on the dictatorship and
because I couldn't afford copies to make
copies they'll reproduce the same
pamphlet 500 times each and distribute
them it got to a point where the
militaries knew their handwriting so as
soon as they stumble upon one they go
and get them but I look at that and I'm
like you know today you have a blog you
know I don't have to copy the same thing
500 times I block and thousands of
people read it by the way in Togo they
like calling me the wassup girl because
I am always on whatsapp attacking the
government
so it's much easier I just when I'm
angry at the government I just make an
angry note and I send it out in
thousands of people sherry you know I'm
really discomposed I'm always angry by
the way
[Music]
so I was talking about the necessity to
showcase our stories because when I
think about the sacrifices that were
made for us it helped me keep going one
of the very first actions of our former
school movement was to come up with a
petition asking citizens to sign so that
we can demand new elections as the
Constitution's allows before I was
scared to put their names because they
said they don't want to get in trouble
even in the diaspora people have scared
like we have family at home but I was
this woman who was in her sisters when
she heard about it she took the petition
and she went home to home and by herself
she collected over 1,000 petitions that
inspired me so much and I was like if a
sister years old that has nothing more
to gain in this regime can do this for
us the young ones then why should I quit
it is a stories of resistance the
stories of defiance the stories of
resilience that inspire people to get
involved not the stories of abuse and
killings and hurt because as humans is
only natural for us to be scared I
wanted to share with you a few
characteristic of dictatorships so that
you can assess your own country and see
you are also at risk of joining us
number one thing to look at
concentration of power is the power in
your country concentrated in the hand of
a few unreleased it can be a political
elite ideological elite and you have a
strong man because we always have one
guy who is presented as a messiah who
will save us from the world then the
second point is propaganda dictators
feed on propaganda they let giving the
impression that they are the saviors and
without them the country will fall apart
and they are always fighting some
foreign forces you know the Christians
the Jewish the Muslims the voodoo
priests are coming for you the
Communists when they get here we'll all
be broke these kind of things and our
account our presidents in particularly
he fights pirates I
am very serious last year he bought a
booth at Stetson million dollars to
fight pirates and 60% of our people are
starving so they are always protecting
us from some foreign forces and this
leads to point three militarization
dictators survive by instigating fear
and they use the military to suppress
dissident voices even but they try to
give the impression that the military is
to protect the nation and the suppress
institutions and destroy them so that
they don't have to be held accountable
so do you have a heavily militarized
country and this leads to a point for
what I call human cruelty you know when
we talk about animals we say animal
cruelty when animals are abused because
there's no chatter acknowledged by the
UN saying animal rights charter points
one all animals are created equal so you
don't have that so whenever animals are
abused we say animal cruelty but when it
comes to humans we say human rights
abuses because you assume that all
humans have rights but some of us
actually still fighting for our right to
have rights so in that condition I don't
talk about human rights abuse of
Violation when you live in a country and
you have an issue of the President and
the worst thing that can happen that he
bans you from the presidency you're
lucky when you come to my country I have
an issue of the president's you just run
you disappear you vanish from the
universe because it can still find you
in Turkey so people like myself you
don't get to live in Togo anymore and
people like myself you don't get to live
in the same place for more than a month
because we don't want to be true the way
they abuse people the type of cruelty
that happens in all impunity under
dictatorships are beyond human
imagination the stories of some of the
activity that were killed that bondage
dumped in the sea that were tortured to
the point where they lost their hearing
or their sights those stories still
haunts me and sometimes on as an
activist I'm less concerned about dying
on how it all happened sometimes I just
sit down and I imagine all scenarios
what are you gonna do either they're
gonna cut my ears first are they gonna
cut my tongue because I'm always
insulting them it sounds cruel but it is
the reality will live in very cruel
world dictators are cruel monsters and I
am NOT saying this to be nice
so yes that is the final characteristic
that I want the list goes on but that's
the final thing I want to share about
autocracy soon as you look at your
country and you Steve there are risks
there it is important that you
acknowledge but gains of freedom that
you have today because some people have
to really realize for you to have it so
you don't take get you don't take these
for granted but at the same time you
also need to know that no country is
actually destined to be oppress where at
the same time no country or no people
are immune to oppression and desertion
thank you
[Applause]